hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
better call salt bonus video about Kim
Wexler and how her story might end we're
down to the final two episodes of season
5 which means we're getting closer to
the end a better call Saul I think now's
a good time to talk about Kim's fate
because we've had a lot of developments
in the last couple episodes and before
we get into it I do have to give a
spoiler warning this video will discuss
everything that's happened through
season 5 episode 8 of BCS and everything
that happened in Breaking Bad if you're
not caught up this video will spoil
things that happen and better call Saul
season 5 that you can't unsee if you're
new to the series and you're just kim
curious I would strongly suggest waiting
until you finish episode 508 bagman
before you watch this video with that
out of the way I will say up front that
I'm making this video because I have no
idea what's gonna happen to Kim after
writing this I am leaning one way in one
direction but what I think is most
interesting here is that all three
outcomes for her fate are possible in
this video I'm going to examine each of
those outcomes arguments for and against
and the various ways each of them can
play out why is what happens to Kim
important while she's a beloved
character this isn't a story about Kim
it's a story about Jimmy transitioning
into the character he was in Breaking
Bad Saul Goodman criminal lawyer that
bears little resemblance to the Jimmy
McGill we spent five seasons a better
call Saul getting to know and Breaking
Bad we don't learn much about Saul's
personal life but based on his behavior
it doesn't seem like Kim Wexler is in
the picture at all
for this reason Kim is a motivating
factor from how we get from Jimmy to
Saul since we hear no mention of her in
Breaking Bad it makes this first
possible outcome fairly unlikely and
that is that Kim is still with Saul
during the events of Breaking Bad I
don't like this possibility for a number
of reasons primarily because it would
take a lot of retelling of the story
post BCS to make it work I think that
appeals to some fans though getting to
see a lot more of this
dori that occurs during the Breaking Bad
timeline and there are a few clues out
there that people who champion this idea
bring up what would the pros be to this
outcome as far as Kim is concerned it
would mean that she's not dead and that
nothing happened to drive her away
because we've watched these great
characters build a relationship and more
recently a marriage it's only natural to
wonder if Kim could still be behind the
scenes while Saul is working with Walter
White as his lawyer one clue that has
made people wonder and try to connect
the dots is that saul has a holding
company he used to move money in
Breaking Bad that's named Ice Station
zebra associates in season 2 episode 6 a
better call Saul in season 2 episode 6 a
better call Saul Kim and Jimmy run a con
together they convinced a stranger at a
bar to write them a check for $10,000 as
an investment in a fictitious tech
startup that they tell him about when we
see the check later at her apartment
it's written out to Ice Station zebra
associates Ice Station zebra is also the
name of the classic movie that Jimmy and
Kim watched together earlier in the same
season that name leads people to
speculate that Kim is still involved and
the theory usually involves a reason why
Kim can't be working publicly in the
office with Saul like losing her law
license in relation to something they
did together the cost of this outcome
are fairly obvious Breaking Bad is a
story that's already been told from
watching Walter White's journey would
the fact that Saul had more going on
behind the scenes really improve that
show in any way it's debatable but I
would lean towards no we've had one
flash forward to the Breaking Bad
timeline in season four of BCS and I'm
not opposed to seeing more but there's
still plenty of room to write the story
of Jimmy McGill transformation into Saul
without rewriting what we already know
Kim and Jimmy were married in May of
2004 so there's still roughly four years
until the two timelines would overlap
one thing worth mentioning about that
flash-forward from quite a ride in
season four is that Jimmy asked
Francesca to be at a phone booth at 3:00
p.m. on
were twelve before they part ways in his
office she agrees to be there to take
this call we know this is Jimmy's
birthday from seeing his driver's
license and that leads people to guess
that Kim would be the most likely caller
who else besides Kim would be planning
to make a call like that one that was
planned well in advance if it is her
then that makes the idea of her still
being together with Jimmy much more
complicated not only would she have to
have been hidden off-screen but she'd
also have to leave him by the time he
uses Edie the vacuum cleaner guy to
disappear while her being the one to
make the phone call would complicate
this outcome it would actually make the
next one impossible that next possible
outcome is that Kim dies it's hard to
imagine this happening and some fans
will tell you that it couldn't happen
but it definitely could there's no
shortage of violence on the cartel side
of this story and for that reason no
character is safe fans love Kim the
creator's love Kim but that doesn't mean
that she can't die Kim has recently made
herself known to the cartel by visiting
Lalo in jail and the fact that Jimmy has
told her about his dealings with them
means she's more than just a family
member that they could use as leverage
to pressure him she knows about their
business and that means she could be a
liability
the only real pros to this outcome is
that Jimmy would be untethered with
nothing holding him back from going full
saw Kim dying would sever all the
remaining ties to that period of time
when Jimmy was trying to be a good guy
trying to do the right thing if we look
at Jimmy after Chuck's death you could
make an argument on how this would clear
his path to where he ends up later Chuck
dying opened the door to Jimmy
practicing law while fully embracing the
conman side of himself after he was
reinstated he changed his name and went
straight to trying to appeal to this
criminal clientele he built up while he
was selling burner phones it's hard to
imagine him doing this if Chuck were
still alive and the other things we saw
what Chuck's death was that Jimmy wasn't
able to process the event he pushed down
his feelings in an unhealthy
Wayne and we just saw them coming back
up when he tore in the Howard outside
the courtroom in Episode seven JMM if
you take him out of the picture
permanently it might be the thing to
push Jimmy over the edge to fully
embracing Saul would it though the cons
of this beyond the fact that killing off
Kim Wexler feels like a crime against
humanity at this point all stem from
that question would he be the guy we met
in Breaking Bad if Kim died he's not a
dark character he's almost
happy-go-lucky
and he definitely seems to enjoy what he
does like he likes being a criminal
lawyer would he be like that if his
early encounters working for criminals
led to the death of someone we can see
that he does truly love there is some
time for healing but to this point Jimmy
doesn't do healing and if he did recover
from the low place he would surely go if
Kim ends up dead would he come out the
other side and jump right back into
criminal law maybe but it would take
some finessing and that's why I favor
the last possible outcome that outcome
is that Kim leaves she's not in the
picture they're not together something
drives these two apart the current
situation with the cartel could be that
thing that finally pushes her to make
the decision to leave Jimmy for good in
that scenario knowing that his decisions
led to Kim becoming the one that got
away could be the thing that completes
his transformation into Saul or Jimmy
fearing for her safety now that Lola
knows about her existence could do
something to drive her away himself a
noble sacrifice to save the woman he
loves even though the price to be paid
would be losing her forever well I like
the idea of her leaving better than the
other two options there are a ton of
potential problems with it as well
primarily the reality of once you're in
you're in
there should be no walking away from the
cartel just because you don't feel like
being involved with them anymore if
you've been on the inside and have
witnessed the workings of the
organization then you're a threat to
bring it down they can't afford to have
loose ends out there in the world which
could put them at risk down the road
after the events a bag man things are
going to be tricky for Jimmy and Kim in
relation to Lalo this has led to the
theory that Jimmy might have to use the
$100,000 he made from picking up the
money to pay heed from the vacuum
cleaner store to help Kim get out of
town while this would answer the
question of how Saul met Ed and knew
about it services while leaving Kim on
the board to be the one who makes the
call Francesca will be waiting for I'm
still not totally in love with this idea
partly because this is something we've
seen happen in the end of so many
characters stories already but also
because I'm not sure it would make sense
that Kim would have to disappear while
Jimmy would be able to just stay and
continue on with his life after the fact
Lalo and the cartel complicate
everything and that's led to the idea
that Kim will figure out some way to
neutralize that threat this is a
promising idea this is an area where
we've seen them shine together in the
past on more than one occasion they work
together well when they have a reason to
and getting out from under Lalo's
influence would be their most impressive
accomplishment to date they could
definitely pull it off and you'd love to
see it but then the question becomes how
does a victory against the cartel turn
into Kim not being around during
Breaking Bad something would have to
happen in this process to drive her away
could doing what becomes necessary to do
be enough to make him decide that she no
longer wants anything to do with Jimmy
McGill it's certainly possible
I should mention because I know I'll get
bombed in the comments that they can't
kill all reason being because Jimmy
fears that he's still alive whenever
Walt and Jesse take him to the desert in
season 2 of Breaking Bad when we first
meet him that doesn't mean that Lalo is
alive it just means that at that point
Jimmy thinks he's alive so they would
have to do something that gets him out
of the picture and for this to fit into
the idea that Kim isn't going to be in
the story any more there would have to
be consequences that come along with it
that would have to make her want to
leave so it is pretty fun that any one
of these could be the possible outcome I
lean towards her leaving not
dying and that would leave things open
for a possible reunion in the gene time
line I'm not a hundred percent on board
with that it's certainly possible he's
in Nebraska we know that Kim grew up in
Nebraska this leads a lot of fans to
thinking for sure that they're going to
at least have an encounter at the end if
not come back together but I'm not a
hundred percent on board with that idea
yet I'm holding out to see what happens
next in the jean story before I decide
if I think that's where they're heading
but in general I do prefer the idea of
her leaving and getting out alive so
tell me in the comments what you think
why do you like whatever idea it is you
think and let's have a conversation
there for what it's worth I don't think
that she'll leave by the end of season
five if that's the way they go I think
that'll happen later if they kill her
off in a shocking way that could happen
at the end of season five but you also
wonder because Rhea seehorn is so great
and this character has carried a lot of
Jimi's story how would they go about not
having her in season six so I'll leave
it there please let me know what you
think about that please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching I will talk to you soon